[Música]
você já reparou que algumas pessoas
dizem que vão mudar
aí eu vou emagrecer emagrece ah eu vou
fazer dieta e faixa eu vou parar de
comer disse para eu vou largar o emprego
vou montar a empresa e para e montam ea
empresa bem sucedida em outras pessoas
que parece que não importa o que elas
fazem a coisa não acontece ela própria a
china ou ela tenta não dar certo isso me
chama muito a atenção que algumas
pessoas conseguem porque algumas pessoas
mudam porque outros com as mesmas
condições não mudam que não sou eu mesmo
emprego que a outra uma infeliz é outra
não é feliz se chama muita atenção vem
estudando isso nos últimos anos porque
as pessoas mudam porque algumas
conseguem outros não consegue ter um uma
tropa americana de elite da marinha
americana que é talvez seja das do dos
exercícios mais difíceis para você
entrar e dos 140 que começam só 36 na
média consegue completar a gente precisa
ser completa que completa marombado mais
forte o mais sarado é aquele que vai
completar a atividade mas não os demais
completam esse exercício e entrou para
essa tropa de elite só aqueles que mais
tome não os seus medos são os que mais
dominam e vencem a sua batalha interior
eu entendi que a maior batalha que todos
nós precisamos vencer
é aquela que acontece dentro da gente
vamos pensar no ipi no índice de domínio
interior pensa numa escala de zero a dez
a zero é a pessoa que perde a sua
batalha interior
quanto mais perto de 10 é aquela pessoa
que mais venceu essa batalha interior ea
legislação todos nós todos os dias da
nossa vida
a gente luta várias batalhas anteriores
algumas mais simples outras mais
complexas nem gente acorda olha por
mário fala assim
caramba cara não tô sem roupa amarrotado
tudo cheio de roupa ou sem roupa nenhuma
não tem nenhuma roupa que sirva só uma
batalha interior algumas matérias são
maiores nos tragam conseguir falar 18
minutos tudo que eu quero falar no ted
ai meu deus e sul e troca de camisa e
atrás que a pizza estava enorme e outras
batalhas são maiores será que o doente
já que eu não tô pra que vou vencer essa
doença que o outro mas tudo é uma
batalha interior
tudo é sobre vc sabe que o mais incrível
quando você vence a sua batalha e
interior talvez varzim
não admito quando venceu uma batalha
interior eu penso que estão lá fora é
mais incrível do que isso quando você
vence a sua batalha interior muitas
vezes as batalhas exteriores sequer
existem mais
elas deixam de existir
é eu tenho um casal de gêmeos ou encarar
hoje estão com sete anos eles tinham 15
e estava uma bagunça danada no quarto
desde a bagunça eu entrei no quarto
falhou acabou essa bagunça aqui cinco
minutos fechado para pensar nisso que
estão fazendo para vocês pensarem nessa
bagunça estão fazendo carol caiu aos
produtos
o papai pelo amor de deus não de joão
começou a rir
gêmeos mesmo pai e mesma mãe minha
televisão mesmo 4 mesma escola o que faz
a casa chorar o que faz ele rio é a
primeira vez que levei meus filhos à
disney agora tem um ano e pouco atrás e
aí eu fui no trem fantasma com a carol o
brinquedo ela mais queria ir
quero entrar em votação continuar embora
carol quando entrou no trem fantasma ela
agarrou no meu braço
baixou a cabeça fechou o olho o pai eu
tô com medo estou sentindo medo eu fui
advogado da união 14 anos no domingo um
colchonete aos 26 anos de idade
passei a advogada da união mudei de vida
instantaneamente foi 14 anos o jogador
mas não era feliz
eu queria mudar de vida em todas as
vezes que alguma coisa que parecia que
ia me tirar daquela vida começava a
crescer
ficava difícil continuar advogado da
união e se aquilo caiu muito difícil e
quero dizer pra mim tá vendo que não vai
dar
você tá ligado nisso quando sede está
vendo que não vai dar não dá
não dava pra mim sempre ficava difícil é
eu percebi ali naquele momento que
existe uma lógica que a gente cria nossa
realidade funciona assim o que eu vejo o
que eu vejo ouço percebo identifico o
que eu vejo eu crio olha só é tão forte
isso que não é o que olha entende isso
não é o que existe no mundo que eu vejo
é o que eu vejo que passa a existir no
mundo é tão forte que eu devia começar a
minha frase todas as vezes que eu vou
falar de alguma
devia começar com no meu mundo é assim
se eu dissesse para você assim complete
a frase o homem é um pensaria assim o
método igual ao outro pensaria ometto de
safado outro estaria homem trabalhador
o meu filho de deus entende no seu mundo
o seu mundo homem é tudo o que você
pensou no seu mundo e aí o mundo que eu
crio pra mim é um mundo que eu sou
franco que foi na alemanha na minha vida
eu cheguei no final de semana e foi
através fui sair na rua primeira rua que
eu fui atravessar de uns três alemães
parados e eu fui para o lado deles e não
vinha carro ficava na travessa no brasil
já estava lá do outro lado na frente e
foi juntando mais gente mais gente daqui
a pouco cada um com seu celular daqui a
pouco não abriu todo mundo foi no mundo
deles não é ok você atravessar se não
tiver aberto pra você
no brasil eu tô falando bem nem mal
estar no fato se atravessa rússia se não
tiver aberto se tiver fechado se não
venha carros e dá uma corridinha fora da
fácil e você correr rápido estava a
atravessar também e assim a gente vive
no brasil é o mundo que eu vivo mundo
que eu vivo é que uns o mundo que eu
crio é quem eu sou eo que eu sou
determina o que eu faço o que eu faço
determina o que eu vou ter que trazer um
exemplo do mundo corporativo pra você
imagina um cara que fala se aqui numa
empresa na empresa só tem aumento
promoção quem anda a patotinha do chefe
quem é da patativa chefe entendimento
que tem promoção beleza no mundo dele aí
chega um dia chega e fala assim
quinta-feira ó onze aqui no trabalho
queria que você puder aqui puder ficar
se até depois das 7 o cara que no mundo
dele não vai ter aumento não vai ser
promovido porque ele é do pacote em que
ele fala o chefe assim não fosse hoje e
amanhã podia ou não podia marcar 18 tem
nada pra fazer
hoje eu não posso queria muito ajudar aí
mas hoje não vai dar
e vai embora porque embora não é nada
tinha a chegada do aumento da promoção o
chefe olha pega lista de pessoas ver o
nome dele esse cara é o cara que nunca
pode ficar e ainda o momento para ele
não promove o que acontece
ele teve
ele teve aquilo que ele viu atrás sabe
que o problema quando ele tem quanto
mais ele tem mas ele vê e quanto mais
ele vê mas ele cria mas ele é mas ele
faz mas ele tem quanto mais ele tem mas
tem acabou de criar o ciclo da realidade
do profissional que não que não é
evoluído do profissional que não tem
promoção do profissional que não dá
certo do profissional que demitiram pra
vida pessoal
marido e mulher eu pude ser mulher podia
ser história da mulher do marido ou do
companheiro ou da companheira não
importa o falando e vou falar como um
homem
vou falar da mulher mas podia ser o
contrário cara chega em casa uma hora e
vinte de atração acabou a bateria ficou
preso no trânsito no ônibus chega em
casa uma hora e vinte atrasado
a mulher chegou um pouco mais cedo do
trabalho ligava pra ele fora de área
já sei me traído
normalmente a mulher sabe com quem ele
pra trás e até com quem é é com a fulana
no lugar tal fazendo tal curso até a
posição com os caras vão lá e aí que
acontece no mundo dela é uma mulher
traída e ficar preso no trânsito quando
ele chega em casa ela é quando ele chega
em casa quem ele encontra uma mulher
traída que faz coisas de mulher traída
mulher traída fala assim a lua
cheguei mais cedo o trabalho hoje quem
tem sua comida quentinha lá tomou banho
vale assistir uma série ou diz assim a
comida tá lá esquenta se você quiser vou
dormir mais cedo hoje como todo bom
humor porque porque a mulher traída faz
coisas de mulher traída faz sentido para
você que acontece e vai ficando falar o
rapaz trânsito horrível hoje vou ficar
aqui mais duas horas no trabalho para
deixar passar o levou para casa encontra
a mulher podia ser o contrário está o de
um homem tanto faz história
ele fica um trabalho mais duas horinhas
a um amigo na terceira vez amigo fala
assim vão tomar cerveja
agora na quarta cerveja aquela amiga do
trabalho ele não colheu o ano em beleza
mento momentâneo impressionante que ele
trai defendendo não só constatando o
fato é quando ele trai a mulher tem
aquela fio e ela termina o
relacionamento começa outro
relacionamento no mundo dela homem é
tudo bem disso e
rio a realidade que eles queriam isso é
mais do que isso você cria realidade ela
cria organicamente você isso um estudo
feito o experimento feito com três
jovens alérgicos
eles tinham alergia alergia a um artigo
a venenosa uma planta vendar os três
jovens esfregaram no braço direito deles
à planta provas pra mim você agora a
planta venenosa esfregou dos eram
alérgicos 2 13
os 13 tiver alergia vermelhidão coceira
bolha agora vou chegar no outro braço a
planta não venenosa mas mesmo sem ser
venenosa dois tiveram alergia
sabe qual foi mais impressionante esse
estudo aqui se esfregou no braço direito
que 100% teve alergia não era planta
alérgica e 100% tiver alergia porque
inventados disseram para ele que aquela
planta era alérgica e no braço esquerdo
que diz ser essa planta não é alérgica
mas era só dois tiveram entende isso a
gente o nosso corpo orgânica' mente
gerou o que eu vim pra mim se faz sentir
em beleza mas é o cara tá parado na rua
vem um ônibus atropela ele perdeu os
movimentos da perna não foi ele que
criou no fórum mundo dele que criou o
cinema do fernando fernando foi um cara
que participou de um reality show famoso
no brasil ele perdeu os movimentos vão
perceber que até na matéria diz aqui que
naquele momento ele não podia voltar a
andar mas ele não voltou a andar
isso não pode mudar mas ele pode mudar o
que ele vai ver
dali pra frente ele não pode mudar ter
sido atropelado mas ele pode mudar como
vai ser um mundo dele e dali pra frente
ele vai ver é o que vai determinar o
fernando com o tratamento em brasília
ligou para a professora de ramos falou
assim posso fazer uma aula de remo
experimental apple pode vem vindo só tem
um problema no mesmo setor ou para baixo
você caramba e agora vai ver que eu dou
um jeito chegou lá puseram num barco
junto com outro remador experiente
treinador falou assim cada vez que o
fernando botava o remo na água
senti a força do rio fernando hoje
sempre acontece isso sempre vejo as
quatro mulheres se inspirando na platéia
sempre mostra foto normalmente dá uma
olhadinha para o lado assim pra ver o
namorado viu a suspiro que ela deu esse
é o fernando hoje
mas é mais do que isso é bíblico a
jerônimo sou ateu eu tenho outra
religião importa o que a gente veio aqui
e veja a bíblia como um best seller na
lista dos mais vendidos do mundo muitos
anos
a bíblia diz em provérbios 23 7 assim
como você pensa na sua alma
assim você é carol e joão tava no quarto
chorando e rindo carol vilton de castigo
com o pai
que merda vão ficar de castigo no bairro
joão viu que eu já estava no quarto eu
pai maluco já estava no quarto e me
mandou ficar no mesmo quarto
vou continuar vendo o meu programa de
televisão e meu irmão está chorando a
linha do mundo e ele riu pra caramba
daquele jeito é a forma como ele viu
quando eu vi cada vez que ouvia mais que
não dava pra ser de deixar de ser
advogado não estava não dava não estava
não dava eu sempre chegava a dizer que
ia dar um dia falei vou parar com isso
jerônimo se fosse fácil todo mundo faria
é a frase do título e pulseira
daquele dia em diante toda vez que eu
chegava mais perto e ficava bem difícil
quanto mais difícil ficar falando nossa
quer dizer eu estou perto de conseguir
largar meu emprego
larguei meu emprego 22 anos e pouco
atrás de lá manter a empresa com uma
pessoa hoje está mudando para um andar
inteiro temos uma empresa
multibilionária escrever um livro best
seller número um da veja todo direito
autoral do livro doado para a causa do
combate à fome infantil todo direito
autoral hoje o mundo de um jeito muito
maior porque botou que eu via minha
filha que agarrou no meu braço e disse
papai eu tô com medo do trem fantasma eu
disse ela sem filha
vocês pode escolher sentiu que você
quiser que você escolhe sentir o pai
então eu escolhi sentir que é tudo
maluco ela acha maluco legal do maluco
foi então ver que tudo é maluco vão ela
me soltou abre o olho no olho é papai
que maluco aquela bruxa sem cabeça olha
que maluca aquele monstro aliás
sangrando sem perna no trem fantasma
ela perdeu o medo não mas ela me soltou
ela passou a fazer coisas diferentes
pelo mundo dela daquele momento em
diante o trem fantasma não era mais
assustador era maluco
eu acredito que um dia todos nós vamos
viver histórias
imagina aquele bom
o vovozinho de cabelo bem branco
contando as histórias dos netos
a minha pergunta que eu deixo para você
hoje é de que histórias você quer viver
só de se ligar a história que vai contar
lá na frente é a história que está
construindo quando hoje não agora porque
a vida é agora e eu verdadeiramente
espero que assim como a carol que
escolheu que o trem fantasma não dava
mais medo e sim ela é maluca partir dali
você escolha que eu possa ter
contribuído para que a partir de agora
você escolha ver que a vida é realmente
extraordinária e você construir
histórias que você lá na frente vai ter
verdadeiramente orgulho de contar
obrigado
[Aplausos]